you had something you wanted to do I
wanted to do it for the people right
Conan I wanted to the hell I wanted to
do something nice for the fans of the
show and so I I had an idea I wanted to
do like a sweepstakes where basically I
wanted to give away a cow give away a
cow yeah I wanted to have people like
submit like the best commercial for the
ranch and give away a cow I thought
people would appreciate that right and
then the lawyers got involved but in
wait a minute wait a minute what's wrong
with Weick well won't lawyers let you
give it why can't you give away a cow i
don't know i don't understand i mean i'm
actually just say i thought you were
like a scientist you're supposed to know
stuff is your is it really true they
said you can't I guess there's other
legal is there some legal issues and the
lawyers were like you can't give away a
cow and I'm like why not like I have a
cow I want to give it away and they're
like you can't just give away a cow like
apparently I don't know there's like if
someone lives in Manhattan and they win
what are they gonna do with the cow but
that's there why is it your problem
why enter the contest yeah even an apart
you know what doing let me tell you
something we don't have a legal team
here at this show those guys cost money
and you know so we don't have a legal
team so we could give it away if you
just want to give away a cow you should
be able to give it what and then I ended
up I got the cow I have the cow but now
I don't know what to do with it I got
the cows here really I was ready to do
the thing and now I can't even though
but where's the cows can you bring the
cow out you hear those really wants to
give a power
that's it this is uh this cow this cows
name's Molly
it's a Holstein cow that's a beautiful
cow a gorgeous cow she's gorgeous it's a
dairy cow guys you're saying you can't
get rid of this town now I don't know
what to do with it so if some day I tell
you what I'd be happy to buy it yeah now
is gorgeous though is it she's beautiful
I just don't know why you can't give it
away Jeff where we allowed to give away
a cow on the show what do mean you
haven't even look at that
what kind of shitty show are we running
here you can just give it away
wait you have a whole legal team it's
like no you can't give away a tech cow I
asked our producers on the phone to a
restaurant probably trying to get a
reservation and he's like yeah I'm
coming in an hour I'm bringing a cow we
can evoke it yeah no I don't want to
milk the cow that's I think I think
we're good
I think we're good listen we'll we'll
find a home for this cow can you find a
way to give it away yeah I mean all
right somebody's getting a cow then on
behalf of
we will figure this out we'll figure
this out somehow and then we'll we'll
come back on the air and tell you how we
did it I just want to know what happens
with the cow well you're taking it well
you're not leaving it with us are you
you just said you were taking all right
okay put this thing in my law we're
gonna take we're gonna take good care of
this cow we'll find it at home and we'll
we'll keep you updated on what happens
to the cow all right this is so not
Oprah this show like
[Applause]
you